this September get ready for a whole new
round of great Netflix programming
headlining the month is maniac which
stars Jonah Hill and Emma Stone as two
participants in a medical study that
goes to Zastrow Slee wrong other
highlights include new seasons of
Netflix originals iron fist and American
vandal along with the original film hold
the dark in fact there's so much heading
to Netflix in September but it's hard to
keep track of everything so we've
rounded up the best new releases to look
forward to next month he has everything
good coming to Netflix in September 2018
a typical season to critics and
audiences love the first season of a
typical which follows a high schooler on
the autism spectrum as he does his best
to navigate school and family life with
comedy and drama in equal measure
a typical was quick to draw in a loyal
fan base and Kia Gilchrist in particular
delivered a winning performance as the
main character Sam season 2 will pick up
right where the first season left off
following Sam's dysfunctional family as
they deal with their particular brand of
atypical drama look for it on September
7th Marvel's iron fist season 2
even though iron fists are the
unfortunate legacy of being the least
liked marble show on Netflix so far that
hasn't stopped the characters from
making an impact lionfish showed up in
the team-up series the defenders and now
he's back with a second season of a
standalone show
be back for more well the new season
managed to rise above the rocky
foundations laid out in his first outing
find out when Iron Fist returns on
September 7th American vandals season
two we didn't think it was possible but
American vandal is getting even more
meta in season two in the first season
the show revolved around a vandal who
defaced a school in season two as
someone named the turd burglar is
spiking the cafeteria food but the line
is blurring between fact and fiction
from scenes of their own show on Netflix
emails between Netflix and the made-up
documentarians who investigated the
original crimes American vandals season
2 is plunging so deep into parody that
is even mocking itself get caught up in
the mystery on September 14th
Bojack horseman season 5 for four
seasons of horseplay and nihilism
Bojack horseman is ultimately stunned
broken and uplifted audiences the story
of a husband sitcom star who's still
trying to chase the dream in Hollywood
it's the kind of show that plays like a
comedy only to sneak up on you with pain
and sadness wondering what can we expect
when season five lands honestly with
Bojack horseman there's no telling so
we'll all have to wait until September
14th to find out Maniac limited series
Netflix has been dropping teasers for
maniac for months now and we're still
not entirely sure what the series is
about the premise is no secret Jonah
Hill and Emma Stone are two strangers
who take part in a pharmaceutical trial
after that all bets are off as the
trailers dive into a montage of paranoia
and alternate realities we do know that
Cary Fukunaga the mastermind behind true
detective and the screenwriter of it is
helming the series which promises a dark
journey into the human psyche check it
out on September 21st
Quincy preceded Jones rose to famous Ann
Perkins on Parks and Recreation in 2009
and she's been going nonstop ever since
the actress is the daughter of legendary
musician and producer Quincy Jones and
now Rashida is turning her sights on
dear old dad with Quincy the documentary
will offer an intimate look at Quincy
Jones professional career and his
private life take a look on September
21st a good cop the good cop marks the
streaming services first foray into
procedural crime shows anchored by
quirky off-kilter detectives a series
stars Tony Danza and Josh Groban as a
father and son both of Boomer NYPD cops
well the father used to be at least
until he was kicked off the force and
sent to jail for seven years now his son
is a straight-laced by-the-book
detective who's trying hard to stay away
from the corruption that London is dad
behind bars I taught him everything I
know except right from wrong
look for it on September 21st Norsemen
season two on the surface Norsemen looks
like a spoof of shows like Vikings and
Game of Thrones but watch a little
longer and you'll find so much more than
that
Norsemen anchors it's many jokes with
its own characters storylines and
surprisingly rich production design well
rather don't you just let me do this
because I know always just my hands are
very cold it's not a comedy style for
everyone but with season two heading for
Netflix on September 26 we'll have
plenty of time to give Norseman a chance
you have something that belongs to me
so we're actually in control here so
hold the dark from Jeremy Sonier the
director of blue ruin and green room
hold the dark is about a writer who
summoned to Alaska to track down the
walls that carried off a woman's son
once he started digging into the case
though he finds that there's more to the
story than he'd realized
Wes welds Jeffrey Wright stars alongside
alexander skarsgård and Riley Keough
look for hold the dark to hit Netflix on
September 28th new original stand up
Netflix always has a few treats for
stand-up comedy fans and September is no
different on the 11 that look for Daniel
sloth live shows the Scottish comedian
will be hitting on a range of
controversial topics with his trademark
humor style on the 18th to look for DL
Hughley in an all-new Netflix special
entitled contrarian with everything from
Black Panther to current politics on the
table it's bound to be an entertaining
show new movies this September you'll
get the chance to explore the high seas
battle for evil ex supremacy and take a
walk on the wild side and you can do it
all without ever leaving the couch on
September 1st to check out action
favorites like spider-man 3 King Kong
and Pearl Harbor
then look for Black Panther on the 4th
Scott Pilgrim vs. the world on the 16th
and Pirates of the Caribbean the curse
of the Black Pearl
on the 25th if watching Topher Grace
lose his mind to an alien symbiote in
spider-man 3 doesn't do it for you you
can also watch him lose his mind in a
haunted house for the 2018 thriller
delirium oh my spider sense is tingling
if you know what I'm talking about the
lyrium arrives on the first side by side
with screamers like Stephanie for
keeping ours and the Texas Chainsaw
Massacre the beginning and on the 17th
make sure you tune in for the witch
2016's most terrifying movie about
Puritans there won't be a lot of new
drama films heading to Netflix in
September but the few that are a
definite winners in particular be sure
to look for Scarface Unforgiven and The
Cider House Rules the oscar-winning
drama about a world war ii orphanage if
you're looking for something lighter the
first of the month is he's a handful of
comedies joining the Netflix ranks
you'll get classics like Groundhog Day
right alongside modern favorites like
Bruce Almighty The Hitchhiker's Guide to
the galaxy and nacho libre new
television Netflix's television
selection is ratcheting up the horror
this month the biggest new edition is
American Horror Story cult which is
hitting Netflix on September 18th
earlier in the month you can also dig
into season three of Quantico on the
second season two of Van Helsing on the
fifth and season seven of Once Upon a
Time on the sick finally crabby a wire
wrapped a baseball bat replica or
whatever and settle in for season eight
of The Walking Dead on the 23rd squeezie
[Music]